We have more breaking news this morning.
We've just learned that
another individual
has been indicted
in the classified documents case
against Donald Trump.
Wall Nada.
But was the man in the red tie
right there
who had been a White House aide
and then follow Donald Trump tomorrow
long ago?
He has been indicted in this case
as well.
CNN's Evan Perez
back with us with the details here Evan.
That's right, John.
Well, not as has been a figure, certainly
that's been central
to this investigation.
Prosecutors
have allegedly been
been trying to pressure him, according to
some of the
lawyers in that in the Trump orbit.
They've been pressuring him
to try to flip,
to try to turn against
the former president.
They say that he never did that.
In recent days,
while not
I was actually seen at Bedminster
alongside the former president,
among a group of aides
who are to have been there with him
as he was waiting to hear
whether Jack Smith
was going to indict him.
And now he's now facing charges.
We do not know
specifics of of the charges
that Norah faced.
But here's the deal.
He was vague.
His involvement here
looms very large
for the former president.
He is one of the people who allegedly
was handling some of these documents
moved some of the boxes allegedly
from the storage room.
Again, this is part of what
Jack Smith
and his investigative team
have been looking at for months.
This is somebody who was very close
to the former president,
you know, began his job as a valet in
in the White House.
You know,
the guy who brought him his Diet
Cokes, for instance. Right.
And then moved down to Mar a Lago
when the former president left office.
And he has been by his side again.
Somebody who witnessed
a lot of the things
that went on down there
and certainly was somebody
that the Justice Department was keen
to try to
to talk to
and try
to get information from at this point.
He's facing charges
alongside his former boss.
We don't know the name
of his current boss. Right.
His current boss
dealing with the nature of the charges.
But you could imagine them
falling within the realm
of what obstruction
and or mishandling
of national security documents
one might imagine
it would be in that space. Yes.
Right.
Based on what
you know, certainly
what witness testimony
was in this investigation, John,
that appears to have been
what the prosecutors
were going at with
the idea that Narda would have been part
of a conspiracy
to to obstruct this investigation.
Again,
that's based on the witness testimony
that was that was taken in this case.
It was clear that
that's what prosecutors
were homing in on.
And the suspicion was that not
for whatever purpose.
And, you know, however he did it.
That's the allegation was that he
you know, helped move boxes
and in some way
assisted the former president
in trying to obstruct this investigation.
Again, we're waiting to see details
of this charge
Everything is still sealed
in this case down in Florida.
And obviously,
the presence of a second person
does lend itself to a conspiracy charge
as well.
Evan Perez, thank you for that reporting.
Joining us now,
CNN senior analyst Ellie Hoenig.
One thing after another,
this is another person
we now
know has been charged in this case.
What might he be charged with?
Literally taking boxes,
we don't know yet. Correct?
We don't know
exactly what he's been charged with.
But let's remember, who Wal-Mart is.
He was Donald Trump's body man and valet.
We know from the prior
reporting in this case
that he was interviewed by investigators
and he said
that originally
he gave a not fully accurate account.
He said he didn't know anything
about classified documents.
He didn't
have anything to do with documents.
Well, it turned out
he was captured on videotape,
moving documents
including into and out of
that storage room.
So the question is,
what is he charged with?
He might be charged
with making a false statement
based on his first statement now.
Could he be charged for moving the boxes?
Not if he didn't know.
So if he's charged with something
to do with mishandling of documents,
he has to have known
that they were classified,
that they were illegal for him.
To have if he was unwitting.
You can't charge him with that.
Another question
that I have is,
is Walt not charged
in the same indictment as Donald Trump?
You can charge.
So here's why it matters.
You can charge people either
each in their own indictment
or you can charge
two, three, ten people
in the same indictment
if he's charged in the same indictment
as Donald Trump.
Then theoretically,
they're headed towards a trial together.
Now, there's a way to separate them.
But the default is
that we tried together.
If they're charged in
separate indictments,
then they're going to be
on separate tracks.
If you're a prosecutor,
does the presence of a second person
in such a major case like this,
how does it impact the bigger case?
Yeah, well,
I think what I'm trying to do
if I'm a prosecutor, is flip what not.
Let's let's get that.
You're still trying to do
even Louis indict.
You're
trying to do it with this indictment
because you can flip
people pre-indictment
you can explain them.
If you don't come on board,
you're facing this type of charge.
But when you actually get hit
with United States, the wall, not a
that has a sobering effect.
So he still has the opportunity,
perhaps if prosecutors are interested,
if he's interested,
we don't know
to cooperate,
meaning to plead guilty
to what they've charged with
and then testify.
We don't know whether that's happening
but I'll tell you, as a prosecutor,
that's what I would be looking to do.
And you always want to flip people up.
You want to flip what?
Not against Donald Trump? Certainly not.
Yeah, that would be preposterous. Yeah.
The other new developments
that we've learned just this hour,
I want to ask you about Donald Trump
announcing that he's
going to be shaking up his legal team.
Todd Bland is taking over Jim Trustee
and another resigning trustee
They put out a statement saying
now that the case
has been filed in Miami,
this is a logical moment
for us to step aside
and let others carry the cases
through to completion.
What do you think that.
It's interesting
I'm pretty sure Todd Blanchard
lives here in New York about
I should say, I used to work with Todd
at the Southern District of New York.
We overlapped for
five or six years there.
And I consider myself
friends, professional colleagues.
I'm not sure how much the Florida
aspect of this matters,
but I will say this.
It wouldn't it all surprise.
It would be a smart move for Trump
to get what we call local council,
someone in Florida
who knows the courts who maybe can relate
to a jury.
Juries care about that kind of thing.
And let me say this,
Todd Blanch is not your typical flame
throwing, table
pounding trouble where he's smart,
he's understated.
He represents Trump in the Manhattan D.A.
Matter as well.
Ellie Harding, thank you very much.
Just to catch our breath
and bring people up to speed,
in the last hour alone,
we learn number one
federal judge, Trump
appointee Eileen Cannon will oversee
at least the initial part of this case.
Number two,
Trump has changed
his legal representation,
getting rid of the people
we've seen on TV
for the last several weeks,
replacing him with Todd Blanch.
And number three,
there is another
a second individual charge
in the classified documents
case, whatnot.
We are following all these developments.
They keep on coming in.